hemos visto varios vídeos acerca del
producto cruz y acerca del producto
punto y de hecho en uno de esos vídeos
obtuvimos esta igualdad recuerdas a
punto b es exactamente igual a la
longitud de a que multiplica a su vez a
la longitud de b y esto a su vez
multiplica al coseno del ángulo que se
forma entre estos dos vectores así que a
ver déjame dibujar estos dos vectores
este de aquí le voy a llamar el vector
am este de aquí le voy a llamar el
vector 20 y este va a ser el ángulo que
se forma entre estos dos vectores que
por cierto todo esto lo vimos en el
vídeo acerca del ángulo entre dos
vectores y de hecho en este vídeo nunca
despejamos la teta así que sería muy
bueno resolver esta igualdad para theta
y que me va a quedar pues yo tengo que
apuntó ven y si yo paso dividiendo la
longitud de a por la longitud debe pues
me va a quedar apuntó b entre la
longitud de a que multiplica a su vez a
la longitud de 20 y esto es igual al
cose no detecta y bueno qué es lo que
queremos despejar a tener y si queremos
despejar de está entonces hay que pasar
la función coseno con su función inversa
del otro lado de la ecuación me va a
quedar que teta es igual al art
cuyo coste no es apuntó ven entra es la
longitud de a que multiplica a su vez a
la longitud de be si muy bien la
longitud de a que multiplica si perfecto
a la longitud debe y lo padre este
asunto es que estos vectores pueden
tener n componentes los componentes que
tú quieras pueden vivir en un espacio de
mil dimensiones si tú quieres porque al
final cuando nosotros tomamos el
producto punto de dos vectores lo
podemos calcular y me da un número real
y cuando yo hablo de la longitud de a y
de la longitud debe también son números
reales entonces yo podría tomar mi
calculadora trabajar con las operaciones
que me den esta parte de aquí y después
decirle a mi calculadora que me trabaje
con el arco cuyo coche no es esto de
aquí o que recuerda que también esto se
le conoce como el coche no en la menos
uno ambas expresiones equivalen a lo
mismo que es la función inversa del
coche y entonces esto me daría un ángulo
que precisamente va a ser el ángulo que
está entre estos dos vectores y también
vimos hace pocos vídeos otra igualdad
importante que eran la igualdad que
tiene que ver con el producto cruz y
decía más o menos así la longitud del
producto cruz de dos vectores
es decir la longitud de la cruz ven es
igual a la longitud de a por la longitud
de ven ya su vez multiplicaba esto al
seno del ángulo que se forma entre estos
dos vectores al seno del ángulo que se
forma entre estos dos vectores que por
cierto es también este mismo ángulo aquí
la única diferencia es que esto está
definido para vectores en r3 porque
recuerda que el producto cruz solo está
definido para vectores en r3 no en
varias dimensiones y bueno ya que tengo
esta y esta igualdad que tengo aquí lo
que quiero ver en este vídeo es entender
perfectamente bien estas igualdades y
ver cuáles son las propiedades que son
parecidas en el producto punto y en el
producto cruz es decir quiero ver una
comparación del producto puntos del
producto cruz dada estas igualdades y
que por cierto en mis series de física
hay un vídeo muy parecido a este donde
hablamos precisamente de una comparativa
entre estas dos operaciones de vectores
y bueno lo primero que quiero que
hagamos es entender de una forma
geométrica estas dos igualdades así que
lo primero que quiero hacer es dibujar
estos dos vectores voy a suponer que
este es mi lector
y estar acá es mi vector ve que no no no
me quedo muy grande lo voy a hacer un
poco más pequeño este de aquí es mi
vector b entonces déjame escribirlo este
es mi lector de esta es mi vector am y
ahora me voy a fijar en mi primera
igualdad que tengo aquí para ver si
puedo encontrar una forma geométrica de
entender esta igualdad fíjate bien este
es el ángulo que se forma entre estos
dos vectores estás de acuerdo entonces
esta primera de aquí va a ser la
longitud del vector a y esto es una
manera muy explícita dejen poner que
esta es la longitud del vector a y
también vamos a poner que esta de aquí
abajo va a ser la longitud del vector
ven lo estoy poniendo de una manera
bastante gráfica y pues claramente se
nota que esta es la longitud del vector
am y ésta de aquí es la longitud del
vector b entonces voy a poner que aquí
esta es la longitud del vector b y bueno
si ya tenemos de una manera gráfica que
es la longitud de ahí que de longitud
deben déjame escribir esto que tengo
arriba de esta siguiente manera la
longitud de m por la longitud de no
espera espera el por lo voy a poner así
porque recuerda que no quiero confundir
el producto punto con el símbolo de la
multiplicación de los números
entonces lo voy a escribir así la
longitud de b que multiplica la longitud
dejada por el coche no beteta yo no me
voy a preguntar quién es la longitud de
a por el coche 90 y para esto me voy a
acordar del show captó a su campo porque
están demotecnia me ayuda a decir que el
goce no del ángulo es igual al cateto
adyacente entre la hipotenusa el coseno
de un ángulo es cateto adyacente entre
la hipotenusa así que vamos a ver este
ángulo que tengo aquí vamos a calcular
su cocina quién es su cocina para esto
tengo que bajar otro cateto aquí para
dibujar un triángulo rectángulo y
entonces quién es el cateto adyacente de
este ángulo pues va a ser este de aquí
te das cuenta esto que voy a dibujar de
rojo va a ser mi cateto adyacente a este
ángulo que ojo muy importante no
forzosamente tiene que ser todo el
vector ven puede ser que solamente sea
un pedazo de ave y de hecho vamos a
suponer que su pedacito debe este es mi
cateto adyacente y ahora hay que
fijarnos en la hipotenusa de este ángulo
pero el de porteros en este ángulo si en
efecto es la longitud de a entonces el
coseno de este ángulo
escribir de la siguiente manera lo voy a
ver como el cateto adyacente que no sé
cuánto vale el cateto adyacente no es
más dejenlo escribirlo de una manera más
ordenada para que no se vea tan feo el
cateto adyacente y éste está dividido
por la longitud de a entonces deben
ponerlo con su respectivo color aquí
está dividido entre la longitud de a y
bueno esto es lo que yo sé de él coseno
de este ángulo ahora qué va a pasar si
multiplico ambos lados de esta ecuación
por la longitud de a entonces me va a
quedar que la longitud de a que
multiplica algo seno este ángulo es
exactamente igual al cateto adyacente y
bueno sin sustituyó aquí el catedral
yacente me va a quedar que el producto
punto de dos vectores es decir esto que
tengo aquí es exactamente lo mismo que
la longitud de b que multiplica al
cateto adyacente al cateto es decente
formado por este triángulo rectángulo
entonces déjame ponerlo esto es el
cateto adyacente que habíamos dibujado
aquí lo que quiere decir que es la
sombra del vector a reflejada en el
vector b ahora ya podemos escribir que a
punto b es la longitud del vector b
o escalada lo que vale el cateto
adyacente pero el cateto adyacente
fíjate en el esquema que estamos
haciendo el cateto adyacente es la
sombra que está reflejada de la longitud
del vector a en el vector b es como si
tuviéramos un foco desde acá arriba y
este foco proyectará la sombra de este
vector a en el vector b tiene unos
vídeos voy a hablar mucho más acerca de
las proyecciones y es justo por eso que
esto se ve así de hecho lo que nos va a
medir el producto punto entre dos
vectores es qué tan lejos o qué tan
cerca están dos vectores por ejemplo si
yo me tomo dos vectores que están más
cerca el uno del otro
fíjate que en este caso voy a tomar que
este es el vector a y este es el vector
de estos sectores están muy pegados el
uno del otro por lo tanto si yo trato de
dibujar aquí un triángulo rectángulo
entonces fíjate que mi cateto adyacente
vale casi lo que vale la longitud de b y
entonces mis dos vectores están más
cerca es decir entre más cerca está en
mis vectores mayor producto punto vamos
a tener entonces que me escribí aquí
tiene
un mayor producto punto en estos dos
vectores porque estos dos vectores están
más cerca el uno del otro o por decirlo
de otra manera van más hacia una misma
dirección o también podemos pensarlo
como que la longitud de la sombra del
vector a proyectada en el vector b es
mucho más grande o mejor lo podemos
pensar como la parte de a que va en la
dirección debe es mayor en estos dos
vectores ahora fíjate si me tomo los
vectores que están más separados que
estos dos que va a pasar pues entonces
trazo aquí un triángulo rectángulo y
entonces date cuenta que el producto
punto de estos dos vectores es mucho más
pequeño porque la proyección de a en b
es muy pequeña o dicho de otra manera su
producto punto es pequeño porque estos
dos vectores no van hacia la misma
dirección la parte del vector a que va
en la misma dirección que el vector b es
muy pequeña y pasaría lo mismo si yo me
tomo el vector b y lo proyecto en el
vector am me daría exactamente lo mismo
por lo tanto yo puedo escribir que el
producto punto de dos vectores es igual
a la longitud de a que multiplica la
longitud de b por el coste no detecta y
eso significa
uno de los vectores multiplicado por el
cateto adyacente y lo que podremos decir
es que el producto punto entonces nos
dice que es el producto de las dos
longitudes de estos dos vectores de las
dos longitudes de estos dos vectores y
esto a su vez lo que nos dice es que
tanto van en la misma dirección en la
misma dirección y no es un paréntesis
son comillas muy bien
es decir el producto punto lo que nos
está midiendo es que tanto van estos dos
vectores hacia la misma dirección y por
lo tanto si yo digo que el producto
punto de dos vectores es igual a cero a
que me estoy refiriendo ya vimos casos
en los que los vectores están muy cerca
están muy alejados pero que el producto
punto de los vectores sea igual a cero
es un caso muy especial porque estamos
diciendo que estos dos vectores si
recuerdas lo que vimos hace algunos
vídeos estábamos diciendo que el
producto punto de los vectores es igual
a cero cuando el ángulo entre ellos dos
es de 90 grados o dicho de otra manera
decíamos que estos dos vectores eran
ortogonales y es que date cuenta que
tiene todas
porque si ahora en estos dos vectores
proyectamos la sombra de a desde este
punto en el vector b vamos a encontrar
que pues no tiene sombra porque el foco
está justo arriba de donde está el
vector am o dicho de otra manera estos
dos vectores no van para la misma
dirección ni tantito y eso quiere decir
que su producto punto es igual a cero
como no hay ninguna parte de a que vaya
en la misma dirección que el vector de y
aquí se ve claramente ni siquiera
podemos dibujar un triángulo rectángulo
entonces estamos diciendo que el
producto punto de estos dos vectores es
igual a cero y bueno ahora vamos a
pensar qué es lo que va a pasar el
producto cruz a ver regresemos al
producto groups nosotros sabíamos que si
tomamos la longitud del producto cruz de
dos vectores esto lo mismo que la
longitud del vector ar por la longitud
del vector b y esto a su vez
multiplicado por el seno del ángulo que
se forma entre estos dos vectores así
que hagamos lo mismo vamos a dibujar dos
vectores y vamos a fijarnos a que
equivale esta expresión que tengo aquí
este es mi vector am este voy a decir
que es el vector b y entonces voy a
tomar el soca tohá
el shock a toa el seno de un ángulo es
igual al do opuesto entre la hipotenusa
está de acuerdo entonces si yo dibujo
aquí mi triángulo rectángulo este de
aquí va a ser mi ángulo de 90 grados
este es mi ángulo teta y entonces me va
a quedar que el seno de este ángulo es
el cateto opuesto que es justo este que
voy a poner aquí este es mi cateto
opuesto en esta ocasión y que no sé
cuánto vale por cierto este es mi cateto
puesto entonces lo voy a poner cateto
puesto entre potter nos a por el deporte
de usas sigue siendo la longitud del
vector
no voy a poner con otro color esta es la
longitud del vector a que es justo lo
mismo que vimos en el triángulo pasado y
bueno entonces si yo despejo de aquí al
cateto opuesto me va a quedar que la
longitud del vector a por el seno del
ángulo es igual al cateto opuesto y
bueno pues voy a hacer lo mismo que hice
hace rato si de esta fórmula que tengo
aquí yo la hago escribo de la siguiente
manera la longitud de b por la longitud
de an por el seno del ángulo que se
forma entre ellos dos me voy a dar
cuenta que la longitud
por el seno de este ángulo es
exactamente lo mismo que el cateto
opuesto en ese triángulo rectángulo y
qué significa tener el cateto opuesto en
este triángulo bueno déjame escribirlo
primero acá abajo me estoy dando cuenta
que entonces si yo me tomo la longitud
del producto cruz de dos vectores el
cateto opuesto de este ángulo lo que me
va a medir es que tanto voy en la
dirección contraria al vector b es decir
que parte de a va en dirección contraria
a lo que va el vector b y fíjate es
curiosamente lo contrario a lo que
estábamos viendo con el producto punto
en el producto punto nosotros hablábamos
de ir en la misma dirección aquí estamos
viendo que tanto vamos en direcciones
opuestas y es por eso que me fijo en la
longitud del vector ven ya esto lo
multiplicó por el cateto opuesto de este
triángulo rectángulo y el catéter puesto
de ese tramo del rectángulo date cuenta
que va en un ángulo de 90 grados
por lo tanto fíjate bien aquí si yo
tengo dos vectores que son ortogonales
el uno del otro
es decir forman un ángulo de 90 grados
estoy diciendo que que me va a pasar
me tomo la longitud del producto cruz de
estos dos vectores pues esto va a ser
igual a la longitud de amd por la
longitud de ven por el seno de 90 grados
pero cuánto vale el seno de 90 grados o
depp y medios pues esto es lo mismo que
1 entonces esto se quedaría así y por lo
tanto en este caso comparándolo con el
producto cruz es justo lo contrario
porque aquí nos topamos que esto se hace
máximo cuando estamos en un ángulo de 90
grados es decir cuando nuestros vectores
son ortogonales porque recuerda que el
seno tiene que ser menor o igual a 1
cosa que era totalmente contraria cuando
yo me tomaba el producto punto de dos
vectores cuando yo me tomo el producto
punto de los vectores me estoy dando
cuenta que el producto punto tiene que
ser igual a cero si los vectores son
ortogonales y cuando el producto punto
es máximo
bueno el producto punto de los vectores
es máximo cuando nosotros tomamos los
vectores que son lineales cuando yo me
tomo dos vectores que son con lineales
como estos que estoy dibujando justo
aquí entonces pasa lo siguiente si yo me
tomo a punto ven pues va a ser la
longitud de a por la longitud
ya esto lo tenemos que multiplicar por
el coseno de cero grados porque son
ángulos con lineales pero el coche no de
cero grados es uno entonces esto se
vuelve completamente máximo va a
depender solamente de la longitud de amd
y de la longitud de b esto es lo más
grande que puede valer el producto punto
de dos vectores en comparación que
cuando nosotros pensamos en el producto
cruz bueno en la longitud del producto
cruz cuando se hace máximo la longitud
del producto cruz estamos pensando en
que estos dos vectores son ortogonales
es decir forman un ángulo de 90 grados y
fíjate bien pues nosotros hablamos del
producto punto decíamos que esto era 0
es decir nos daba el valor mínimo bueno
aquí entre comillas pensando que el
producto punto es mayor que 0 o
tomándonos el valor absoluto del
producto punto porque también el
producto punto negativo ya ver qué va a
pasar cuando yo me tomo la longitud del
producto cruz de dos vectores de dos
vectores que son con lineales y mediante
que tengo estos dos vectores aquí el
vector a y el vector b si te das cuenta
el ángulo entre estos dos vectores pues
es cero vamos a la misma dirección y por
lo tanto si yo me tomo la longitud
la cruz de esto va a ser igual a la
longitud de a por la longitud de b por
el seno del ángulo que se forma entre
estos dos vectores pero el seno del
ángulo que se forme entre estos dos
vectores es cero y por lo tanto cero por
lo que sea me da cero y entonces en este
caso la longitud del producto cruz de
dos vectores es mínimo toma el valor más
chico que puede ser y si a esto mismo lo
comparamos con el producto punto el
producto punto curiosamente en este
momento toma su valor más grande que es
la longitud de a que multiplica a la
longitud de b y cosa que es
completamente lo contrario a cuando
tenemos dos vectores que son ortogonales
porque cuando son ortogonales recuerda
que la longitud del producto cruz de
estos dos vectores es máxima porque toma
la longitud de a por él la longitud debe
solamente depende de las longitudes de
estos dos vectores
sin embargo cuando nosotros tomamos el
producto punto de estos dos vectores
cuando estos dos vectores son
ortogonales pues ya sabemos que el
producto punto de estos vectores que son
ortogonales es igual a cero y esto es
porque recuerda que el coseno del cero
es cero y entonces todo se cancela
estamos tomando el valor más
el valor mínimo de el valor absoluto del
producto punto de dos vectores y bueno
curiosamente lo que más cuesta trabajo
es el producto cruz así que quiero ver
otra interpretación del producto cruz
para acabar este vídeo no voy a tomar
otra vez dos vectores este vector a este
vector ven y ahora lo que voy a hacer es
un paralelogramo un paralelogramo que
tenga sus lados paralelos estos dos
vectores algo así y ahora me voy a fijar
en el área de este paralelogramo y bueno
tienes el área de este para él logramos
sí nosotros recordamos la noción de
geometría básica me vas a decir o esto
es la altura por la base la altura que
es justo esta que estoy dibujando aquí
este es un ángulo de 90 grados ya esto
de aquí le llamamos la altura entonces
déjame escribirlo la altura ya esto lo
multiplicamos por la base entonces el
área en este caso sería la altura por la
base pero la base es la longitud del
vector b entonces me va a quedar la
longitud del vector ven por la altura
ahora recordemos que aquí tenemos un
ángulo el famoso ángulo
entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí y voy a
pensar otra vez en quién es el seno del
ángulo theta el seno del ángulo theta
acordándonos es el cateto opuesto entre
la hipotenusa es decir esto es lo mismo
que tener la altura que pinta de rojo
entre la hipotenusa que es la longitud
del vector a muy bien este es el seno
del ángulo y si de aquí despejo a la
altura me va a quedar que la altura es
igual a la longitud del vector am por el
seno de este ángulo que se dibuja entre
estos dos vectores y bueno ahora voy a
sustituir aquí arriba que me va a quedar
el área de este paralelogramo es la
longitud de ven por la longitud de amd
por el seno que se forman entre estos
dos vectores y quién es esto esto es
justo lo mismo que la longitud de la
cruz b es decir la longitud del producto
cruz de estos dos vectores así que ya
tenemos otra interpretación del producto
cruz la famosa longitud del producto
cruz de dos vectores es exactamente
igual que el área de este paredes
logramos que estamos dibujando aquí es
decir nosotros nos tomamos el producto
cruz del aspecto
y nos da un vector bueno pues la
longitud de este vector que vamos a
obtener en la longitud del vector
resultante es exactamente igual al área
de este para el dow gramo que tenemos
aquí y bueno así ya tenemos otra
interpretación de esta longitud del
producto cruz de dos vectores y bueno
con esto acabó este vídeo y espero que
te haya servido para entender las
diferencias y comparar el producto punto
y el producto cruz y entender mejor
estos dos conceptos